oops I think I just got caught up
listening to yung lean well anyway I'm
back and it's not a theme this thing
this beautiful hot I need to stop
looking at it actually theme it where am
I had control yourself um no hedges
today I'm well that may be what did I
just moms have in place hedges somewhere
then eventually somehow but that's not
what I need to do right away what I need
is some fences and primarily ones that I
haven't really overused yet but first I
need hedges okay ah thank God these
things are too good there's not a whole
plethora of options when it comes to
hedges but the ones that are there is so
amazing and I need some more of this
stuff those noise statues because
there's not really anything else that
you can decorate your eyes with speaking
of that decorating I am should not
research any shops and stores anymore
because I got everything that I need
we've got food we've got ice we've got
drinks we've got information and we've
got bathrooms and oops we do need some
of these handyman I'm sorry because you
know they do come in I'm clips and I'm
not going to lie and what else do we
need I don't really think we need a map
thing yet and I don't want them to have
umbrellas because if it's raining
they're not going to enter any right
anyway so it doesn't really help to give
them umbrellas although extra money hmm
I might actually be made you know what I
might actually be able to make some
money off of this even though there's
nothing useful to sell with their people
might still buy it i think i just
realized what capital with the true face
of capitalism is like alright cool and
this guy's already mowing the grass can
we not oh my okay well at least i didn't
fire him you know I'm in a good mood so
I'll cut him some slack but next time he
won't get off that easy
and more hedges because you know we need
some of that I also like this fence if
you pay close attention or if you know
anything about me playing roller coaster
can three I always use the same objects
especially when it comes to fences and
hatches as you can probably tell by now
and we've still got hundreds of bikes to
go yes it's going to happen and but
that's just because these fences are the
ones that look good and the in-game
parks rarely use these fences I as well
so I don't think it's really too good of
an idea to actually use those things
what's the clock in ICT to then I
suppose it was because i can remember
this clock thing but i haven't seen it
in any park yet know what this needs
needs more cherry blossom trees because
are my those things are pretty and some
of this stuff and obviously some of my
favorites chinese sedo or whatever this
thing is called the chinese cedar I was
right beautiful thing I'm not even
kidding i love this tree so got that and
probably need more litter bins even
though there's nothing to throw away yet
i know that i'll forget it later on the
park has already placed some benches for
you I suppose that's nice actually you
don't really have to do too much of the
path work either so it's a very nice
point it's a very nice bike when it
comes to that and looks like people are
enjoying the shipwrecks I mean I'm sorry
there's an exclamation point shipwrecked
hmm so that's good
and since it's not it's a it's a ride
called shipwrecked we might add some
dolphins you know this is I know it
doesn't make any sense but this is just
an excuse to get dolphins in there
because dolphins are amazing please
don't judge me and you know this looks
good I suppose it does the goal of this
series was to get a pike that looks as
nice as possible but the problem is that
it doesn't require as much concentration
as it does in Monaco second three more
than just experience really and the
problem with that is is that I just keep
being distracted about every single
thing that happens I'm very sorry about
that oh well as long as the end result
is good and she's gonna place these
things again and this little place needs
now that's too close to the park however
could use one over there and one over
there I don't know why they've only
added them in this little corner doesn't
seem to make too much sense to me well
I'm not gonna add the connection yet
because I do feel like I do want to add
something over here and I don't know
what this thing is researching we did
get the mine train roller coaster I do
need to see how much money i can
actually get ah yes i can get plenty of
money dude i can just build an
expedition everest if i really wanted to
this is gonna make things way easier you
know I might actually can i buy all this
land not not really that's a shame no
perfect case scenario is i would take
this little thing and change the ground
into this brown thing and then just
create an enormous mind train over here
that would have been so much fun sadly i
can't do that that's a shame
well I can place a ride over there so
I'm just gonna build a little twist a
twisty thing where should it be just
kind of like over there I'd say yeah and
a small Q yellow of course because
yellow is a beautiful color I have never
said anything negative about yellow and
I never wanted to not use yellow cues
that was that definitely never happened
come on okay I don't know if that's the
best q I've ever made it's not as a
terrible q I suppose this is better
slightly good enough let's open the ride
we have any more names for this because
there are so many egg puns didn't we
already that's not how you spell
exquisite isn't it like a French yeah
that's it and it's the exquisite the
exquisite China kind of
yeah that is beautiful it's open a path
to that because it does seem like I do
have many guests maybe it's time for
some campaigns am I mean sorry it's time
for some campaigning as I'm as I stupid
references that's why why why would I
even make a jibjab reference in any case
I need a food where's my food court
going to be that this seems like
excellent place for that so I suppose
nothing really happened while I went out
to take a [ __ ] so that's cool we need
some interesting food pizzas it's a lot
of delicious we need those things oh god
that guess that's gonna be lost hold on
let me save that poor soul because
apparently people in rolla cosec and
three have no idea of how they're how
everything works in life basically they
get lost so easily it's quite stupid I
suppose that's actually something that
they've made batam roller coaster grand
three at least the guests on total
nitwit but other than that it's they're
still stupid because that got drown
anymore because so you know just kind of
that's the compensation I suppose but
it's not really welcome i'd rather have
guests that kind of lose their way all
the time then guests that don't drown
because of course drowning guests is one
of the selling points of roller coaster
[ __ ] as you all know okay let me place
that thing the drinks tall do we have
any names for this I don't think so so
I'm not going to rename it that's
unnecessary what is necessary however
we've got an open space and as we all
know we need to film those things with
fountains much better and we need some
but fun to work around that also get
that excitement rating up for that
ferris wheel because it's already so
high ah first we all sure are exciting
actually i think they actually are i
actually think that guests over in 10
second of underrating Ferris wheels
because as long as you've got a big one
of course all of that came out wrong as
long as you've got a big ferris wheel I
mean it's loads of fun then again I well
this one is kind of small
yeah so I suppose I'm actually with them
on that but you know the average ferris
wheel which is pretty big it's actually
cool i like them it's nice to just have
a quiet look around the park or if you
have the London Eye for example that's
some fun too oh well that's our nice
little food court might want to have
some nice trees with that as well oh yes
so would you like a food court okay if
you like some nice trees with it food
court nice okay I think those trees are
nice however we need more Grunch rubbery
so I'm gonna place that as well you
never have enough of that [ __ ] and what
else is though Chinese here what with
Syria so hard to pronounce that word
well I don't think so just that one tree
over there now with the problem with
this game is the fact that all these
trees are in the Halloween theme so you
can't actually plays them yourself so if
you do decide to remove some of them and
you actually later on the site that you
want them back there's no way to get the
mac because as you can see they are not
that but these ones kind of look like
them so sort of works but it's not all
that legit it's not that great I need
these trees it's not too many people use
a hold on let me look at their common
you hmm it's not all that common if I
look around this park only three of them
and one of the one of these things which
all of these things are just called
shrub that's quite a shame I mean it
would actually be cool if these things
had a name as well and the only thing
that this this game needs or lack
cerrado is flower flowers stuff
basically yeah I mean sure we've got
these things but they're not really like
n7s well ornamental shrubs or anything
like that we don't have nice of roses or
all other cool stuff anyway I think
there's something that I need to work on
first let me do some [ __ ] saving as
always very important must not forget
and in the meantime we got oh that's
actually a very good attraction I like
that and this seems like just the spot
for this thing it's barely anything else
here and just a very cramped little
place so might just get am just get that
tree out of the way and then place that
thing it seems like a good area for the
queue and then all we need is a small
pot and we're done here yeah I don't
know what why but I just don't like
these paths I mean they work sometimes
but not with the paths of roller coaster
tycoon one without the expansion packs
or at least that's just my opinion
they're just very different but I do
like them in some of the scenarios
especially of course the corkscrew
Follies scenarios as that one scenario
with that enormous hyper coaster which
actually looks really good with those
paths ok let me finish this and remove
that link there we go and I don't think
I actually have a name for this thing
but this is just going to be the
limewire there we go and it's a sealer
it's a see related attraction let's play
dolphins place dolphins oh my god and
these things and the Chinese see you
because I do need those things actually
do ok so that's looking fancy too fancy
I will always say and I don't think I
have any fences next through water from
I don't know if I care but in an ideal
realistic situation you would not have
that I'm pretty sure you know what we
need we need some of this some of these
borussia's but actually what you call
those things well it's stupid
okay oh well they look cool so I'm just
gonna place them something to play
someone along the lake I mean it's kind
of empty as of now and I don't like
emptiness and I can place them there as
well and that'll be about it for now but
there is more there's definitely more
there is a looping coaster I am NOT
going to build a shuttle I have promised
that I would not build a shuttle because
if that's what an easy way and how long
have you turn off the research of the
roller coaster to give I've kind of got
enough now if there's one easy way to
finish this game it's just place shuttle
coasters everywhere because it's just an
easy way to get money they're very cheap
and people are willing to pay loads of
money for it and they're safe and
reliable and efficient and everything is
good the only problem is they're not
that realistic or created so I'm not
going to do that last time I did this
park I had a loop in Costa which kind of
went around this hill like I had it
built on the side of this hill but
there's no way I can do that right now
because I at the station over here and
that area is kind of used by this little
coaster now I just realized it's very
important that if you want a realistic
park is that you either really create a
section in the park for a specific
roller coaster this compact and actually
keep the scenery and related to just
that one section or make the roller
coaster very long and stretched out and
not compact at all I think that seems to
be the most realistic way to or at least
most aesthetic way to play around with
stuff in this game and I think it's I
don't know is it's time for the looping
roller coaster over a mine train roller
coaster over I don't feel quite like
building a wooden roller coaster I think
I'm just gonna try a looping yea though
then again this doesn't really seem this
seems more like the area where I could
place flat rides this is the only flat
place I've got left around the lake yeah
I've got this little place but nothing
else really so I should probably save
this up for
big little square or something like that
and actually place the roller coasters
somewhere else but question is where do
i do that mmm it's not easy I'm being
cheap I'm sorry um David I don't know
where to place this thing or what to
make it like really it's hard I should
see where i can actually buy land yeah
it's just kind of all around the park
but not too much so quite restricted
when it comes to that and it's a shame
that I can't buy this area would have
liked to do that though still this is a
very big map even without buying
anything so I should be able to kind of
do stuff without having to buy you
things hmm and good and if I build it
there then this is not going to be quite
an efficient park hmm what if I just
build a mini mine train roller coast
through like in the center of this kind
of like the Hyde Park as in what I'm
gonna mess around with that I'm gonna
try that I am gonna try that and i'm
going to terraform this area and theme
it I want a my train actually I'm gonna
research scenery and theming maybe get
some of that nice theming out there and
maximum funding already excellent we
already get a thrill ride so I'm not
going to research that I'm gonna
research scenery and theming in the
hopes of getting mine theme and
otherwise i'm just going to punch myself
okay so i'm going to create a little
platform on which i will create this new
masterpiece that's beautiful very nice
excellent hold on that's not a good idea
i should start off with the ride itself
and then actually sculpt the environment
around it so let me try that very nice
and then we are going to go over there
and go up hell yes that's beautiful
actually what i can do is do that and
just get a longer train you know that
should be cool but then again that's not
very realistic is it I'm just going to
make the platform bigger like that it's
going to be even more expensive and hard
to theme but I do want this right to at
least be somewhat decent does that even
look good I have no idea it might be too
small actually and this is not quite
what a good right looks like is it I
have a bit I have a better idea we're
gonna enter the tunnel oh yes I can
already see this happening this is going
to be the tunnel this is going to be a
small mountain part oh yes beautiful and
this is going to be the little hold on
no this over here is going to be the
lift Hill where I'm going to raise stuff
oh nice why is it still underground view
hmm and over here i'm going to add a
small something all right no that
doesn't work in that case I'm just going
to make it smaller hot on that probably
wouldn't work either no no that doesn't
work hmm hmm damn this is hard much
harder than I expected what if I am hmm
do something with that and then the day
now that wouldn't fit either hmm this is
surprisingly hard I try to make a very
small and compact to ride but then again
it shouldn't be too boring either you
know what this this big mountain ething
over here just doesn't work no I'm gonna
not do it like that
I'm actually going to try and make this
thing and then make it go down this way
they can be more compact without looking
awkward and ugly mmm that does that
actually work perhaps a helix over here
that doesn't fit a helix over here then
that actually does fit I did not expect
that but it looks it looks terrible hmm
he looks over here then hmm no that's
not that bad I might actually be able to
do that and then again it doesn't look
that good either hmm this is hard this
is actually hard like I had a sort of
idea in my head but it just doesn't come
out that way and that definitely does
not fit hmm I'm actually getting stuck
in here what can I actually move it over
there well I be able to interview to do
something with that I need to see that
by the way if I want to actually try
this now that wouldn't work like that oh
I'd be able to do that perfectly fine
I'll wait icon okay so can't do that
either I I do kind kind of wanted to do
something over here okay and this is
definitely way too big and it might
actually be able to do something like
that but then again it would be too
small and it definitely can't pass under
under that
mmm this is surprisingly hard let me try
that energy it actually kind of works it
actually kind of works but then I still
have an empty space over there oh god
whatever way I do it just doesn't work
in that case I'm going to make the area
bigger screw it and I'm just going to
keep straight lift hills and I'll just
buy land over there I want to get this
thing done somehow and actually theme it
nicely because just a nice and themed
rider something that I want to try in
roller coaster tycoon and I've never
really done it like this that definitely
doesn't work um oh god this is hard you
know I could do in here I could do he
likes actually but that's also hard to
fit in there hmm this is just one big
mouse click fest at this point and the
classic curve like that doesn't really
work out either this is surprisingly
hard okay I'm just going to try it like
this I'm gonna go down I'm going to go
down like that and at that point go back
to the station is that too soon it seems
a bit too soon doesn't it what I could
do no wait that's to know that
definitely doesn't work either
in which case I'll just try a big curve
over here screw it i'm going to go down
like that yeah with a nice little helix
and then i'm going to turn around get
over there and see if i can actually
make that which I can surprisingly